[Music]
how would you suggest to people
listening who maybe let's assume they're
in not cash potato shave 150 pounds in
weight but that they have their non
athletes who were in reasonable shape
but have no military experience haven't
been exposed to any maybe real but they
would consider physical hardship in a
long time
how does someone like that if they think
to themselves I would like to become
harder to kill what would your program
or recommendations look like for them
hardest things about me trying to
inspire encourage people to train as
they look at me and they're like that
guy's freaking Savage
it was a Special Forces sniper Ranger
qualified Green Beret that's been to
combat 12 times fought in the UFC ranked
top two in the world he's a black belt a
handful of martial arts you know but I'm
the exact same person as every other
seven billion people on the planet right
like I didn't grow up with any
kryptonite in the fridge you know like
there's nothing that is different about
me any in any way shape or form I just
work the eyes and I'm just fighting at
this point I'm fighting for not even 1%
to get 1% better I'm fighting for like
percentages of a percent you know I
increment only like decimals like the
tiniest little bits just for that much
of improvement like I long for the day
where I would get dramatically faster in
a month that if I was 20% body fat I
could be 18% body fat
freakin cool that would be if I right
now if I could just lose 2% body fat
meaning you're envious of the people who
have more as a sort of percentage to
gain if they started doing things in
terms of training and so on but you just
said it you know if they just started
doing things that's it all you have to
do is start sort of like everybody so
where do I start man anything you can
get up if you if you don't walk around
if you haven't gotten up and walked down
your block a couple of times do that if
you haven't googled where the closest
martial art gym is whether it's judo
whether it's you Jitsu or it's Muay Thai
whether it's wrestling doesn't matter
you haven't done it try it you know if
you've never
gone to a shooting range and shot give
it a whirl if you've been eating fried
food for like three meals as three
dinners out of the week try to write you
know like just anything will make you
just that much better and then those
little tiny decisions start building on
top of each other and then sooner or
later you look back and you you don't
even recognize the person that you are
there's such this beautiful change
really oh my god I can I can see my dick
you know like I can see my feet or my
wife for the first time in five years
I saw her look at me when I got up and I
walked out of the room and not like
looked at me like thank God that guy's
getting up and leaving but like god damn
that guy look good right you know like
when was the last time in some people's
lives that they felt that way about the
person had been living with retaining
years right you know like make that girl
fall in love with you again you know
impress the [ __ ] out of her you know
where's last time that you picked up
both your kids and like ran to the play
gym with them boy stood on your
shoulders and like put one up on the
other one the other ones you're holding
the hand you hand them on the play Jim
like that's some massive masculine [ __ ]
yeah you're just playing with your kids
on a play Jim yeah you know but there's
this opportunities and there's so many
of them for us just to embrace our
potential which is usually I mean you
know more about it better than almost
anyone the planet because you've pushed
that limit so many times in so many
different ways both intellectually and
physically like there's so much
unrealized potential back to me at 21
years old little piece of [ __ ]
self-absorbed ethnocentric prick on what
like unrealized potential there's like a
hundred and twenty hundred and forty
million Americans right now and I just
have total unrealized potential I just
go just go get started just start
you